all right so this is nightmares and
daydreams and this is the episode where
it's four days before the big attack and
it's pretty much just them resting
before the big attack and feeling this
incredible pressure beforehand and
getting really stressed out having these
nightmares sort of what safai nightmares
actually of him facing the Firelord but
he doesn't have pants or it turns out he
didn't stay for the math test like stuff
that obviously doesn't connect but he's
only like oh no and it's him trying to
deal with his stress his stress and his
pressure and everyone else trying to
help him out with it and on top of that
you have Zuko who's finally invited back
to the the war meeting and he's not sure
how to feel about that well first he
doesn't think he's invited but that
turns out like he actually has like a
seat next to his father as father's
doing very welcoming like then we even
start the meeting until he shows up so
yeah so all that stuff is going on and
let me say that I really identify with
this episode with with Aang because
anytime there's a big shoot coming up
like I do like a suburbanite to boldly
flee or even if I know shoot is probably
gonna be easy
I still get like I get these dreams
sometimes then I understand this
pressure in fact when it actually came
to them saying like oh we're four days
ahead of schedule aang it's like four
day Jimmy it's four days until the
attack I got a train it's like I felt it
man I'm like yeah dude you got four days
come on be ready make sure you and I go
screw up make sure not a the stuff is
gonna happen so it's like I really felt
the pressure and I thought that they got
it really good uh just sort of anxiety
you can get before going into something
big before something that so many people
rely on you want is about to take place
so I thought they'd capture that really
well but also captured the comedy of it
to all the various ways they're trying
to calm them down even to a point where
Aang decides he's not going to sleep
anymore
there's a few fake outs that are pretty
funny the bit where Aang
kisses Katara and says they loves her
but it turns out it's all in his head
the reason that really works is the kids
delivery which at first I thought oh my
god is this like the big I love you
scene and this is how the kid is doing
it really you know like he's like he's a
zombie or something then he realized all
that it was all in his head that's why
he was saying it as a zombie and that
scene is now hilarious because of it uh
some good jokes in this one too I roared
with laughter when they're all telling
him he needs sleep and then Appa tells
him he needs sleep do that that's an arm
of those I had to rewind and see it
again I mean that just destroyed me um
and you know what a great twist that
would have been if it turns out Momo
could talk this whole time I mean what a
twist that would be I was
actually kind of disappointed they
didn't um like I said that's just one of
the lesser characters in my opinions
like Wendy become just infinitely
fascinating if it turns out this whole
time he could talk and he was keeping
silent oh um so yeah the comedy is good
at it I guess I think the capture the
anxiety and the pressure really well in
the dream sequence I I think they're
making fun of other animes or sort of
paying homage and amazing.i right it
looks like the first one might be dragon
ball and then the second might be Naruto
and the last one I have no clue I could
be wrong I don't know I'm not huge into
anime but I think that's what they were
going for uh which is which is fights
I'm sure it's like analyzer something
like that I don't think it's like a
mean-spirited it's like this so if
that's even what they're doing I'm not
sure it looks like they were directly
targeting something but I'm not entirely
sure that's that's what is um the I
think the only
it's kind of a major problem and it's
it's a decent nuff episode by was her
watching this and again I'm saying above
if they're getting this really good I
was trying to calm down but he can't if
anything he feels he has to try harder
and because he's still having nightmares
he feels he's not good enough so he has
to try harder and harder and that at the
very end he just needed the support of
his friends you know
Ferrand ah nice enough but somewhere
like in the third act it sort of just
gives up doing anything and just shows
the dream it's like that one god-awful
episode of The Sopranos years ago where
I think about halfway through her again
maybe at the beginning of the third act
it was just hey here's his dream and
nothing else and there's no real insight
anymore and there's no connection to
plot and there's not really even that
much character it's just
Zayn eNOS it's just surrealism and for a
guy who loves that stuff for a guy who
loves you Big Daddy key to movements and
yo scenes like the pink elephants from
Dumbo is I mean I love these scenes uh
this thing grabbed me I thought it was
just so not connecting to anything and
just being goofy for the sake of being
goofy and maybe that's fine for some
people maybe it's like hey we just
needed a goofy episode we just needed
something really silly this seems very
much like those anime episodes where
they do go all out goofy and all out
strange and weird
uh those don't just they don't grab me
that much um and it's not the whole
episode like I said it's only like the
last third and even that does come back
at the very end to the story but I was
saying to myself oh boy couldn't they
have there's so much going on in this
show can they develop a little something
else in this time why couldn't they show
maybe a little bit more Zuko or a man
like even Zuko I mean it seems like
three episodes ago we know what his
thing is we know that hey he thought he
was gonna have his honor restored and
feel good and he doesn't why because he
didn't do the right thing
and granted it takes time to come around
to that but can we speed it up a touch
you know I and not to say the scenes
didn't work you know you see him go to
the meeting well actually the meeting is
kept off-screen I thought that was a
smart choice uh but he comes out he
looks at the picture and may is there
and she says haha well isn't this
exactly what you wanted isn't this all
you ever want he's like it should be and
yeah we know we got it you know we got
this like three episodes ago so but
anything sort of emphasizing that he's
going to either turn or that his life
should be perfect and it's not her but
what am I looking for anything that
emphasizes that he that he kind of
should be feeling loved or he feels he
should be feeling loved and isn't it is
not bad but like I said we could either
look at from a little bit more of a
different angle or speed it up a touch
because like I said I mean it's you know
where it's gonna go as soon as they say
yes they're gonna have the meeting with
you you know exactly how it's gonna end
or when he's given a big speech at the
beach when he's like you know I'm not
angry with my father I'm not angry with
you or anyone else then who are you
angry with we all know he's gonna say
voice oh so uh again I mean it's it's
not bad I mean nothing in there was like
oh geez come on but I am saying my son
yeah let's kind of get this role in here
I was really shocked to see that like
the next episode is the attack I mean
God they you know the thing they're
trying to get to in each of these
seasons doesn't happen till usually like
the last five or six episodes and here
it's like I think I'm on disc two and
it's already like the thing they were
looking to get to so again like that's a
good that's a good surprise I didn't
know we would get here this early and
then you say to yourself well that's not
the
ending what is the big ending well what
else is going to happen here that's
where the real fun of the story is is
not knowing where it's going to turn
because obviously something has to go
wrong then during the attack and what is
that going to result in and what that's
gonna keep you coming back so I'm
looking forward to that as for this
episode there's definitely a lot
elements I've really enjoyed about it
when it just turned into the silly dream
and nothing else it was it was a little
rough for me I'm just saying am i
substance give me substance you're so
good at that show uh but I know there's
a lot of people that like this goofiness
just for the sake of being goofy and it
going all out silly I given the
animation style gets really really silly
so in that your thing great I mean
there's no like great offense in this or
anything I just fell I I could have had
more connection with the characters and
stuff um
but yeah there it is when they did
capture the pressure and the stress I
thought they captured it very well and
in a funny way so I definitely liked
this episode so that's it for this one
boy the big attack is the next episode
I'm curious to see how it all gets
up so um or maybe it goes well
and then the next episodes are just then
living happily ever after would that be
strange so yeah I look forward to seeing
that one and I will see you there as
well